warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is
advised oh my God Senator Kennedy has
been shot in the head in June 1968
24-year-old Palestinian refugee Sahan
Sahan shot dead presidential candidate
Robert Kennedy in a hotel
Pantry more than 40 years later he still
claims to have no memory of committing
the act I don't remember I must have
been too hypnotized too much out of my
senses to really be aware of of what
happened it was obvious that he had been
uh programmed to kill Robert Kennedy and
programmed to forget that he been
programmed we we've seen videos over the
years of um people being able to take
and um groom basically hypnotize using
neurol linguistic programming there's a
guy named Darren Brown he wanted to
prove that you could actually take a um
an assassin and cause him to do an
assassination outside of his even
it but that just shows that there's
there's a wide variety of reasons why
you could cause somebody to go and do
that and you know it's like it was such
a strange thing but I think people need
to have yeah the overarching backing up
rather than getting caught on the
details backing up and going okay
where's this going and what did this
cause and as the people in the world are
saying and some of those in the think
tanks are saying either way a victory
for Trump or a victory for Cala could
could lead to a civil
[Music]
wall hey everybody Welcome to a special
edition of what's up Prof and led live
Blended together I'm excited about this
episode you guys have an awesome
ministry Walter VI Martin Smith you guys
are all the way from South Africa and
coming and blessing us every time I see
your stuff it blows my mind I mean I'm
I'm I'm shocked but not shocked and I
think it's awesome that there's Watchmen
on the wall literally bringing to the
Forefront things that are going on in
the in the world making sense of that
and I'm excited to get in this
conversation cuz the world seems like
it's coming apart real quick so welcome
to the show thank you thank you very
much what are we going to talk about
today we're going to talk about current
events and how they dovetail with
prophecy all right we know that
according to the Bible there will be
religious legislation MH it it's called
legislating The Mark of the
Beast and we know that that is religious
legislation because it deals with
worship mhm and once it deals with
worship it's dovetailing with the
religious sentiments in the
world and how are these going to come
about in a world that is as secularized
as we have it currently but The Divide
between the secular world and the
religious world seems to be widening and
the conflict seem to be
increasing and the question is is that
heelan dialectic to bring about a
certain synthesis a certain change of
sentiment and we want to look at current
events particularly with regards to the
elections in the United States the
assassination attempt on Donald Trump
and what the ramifications are and how
can this play into the prophetic profile
and this is exciting because for the
first time we really can see a movement
in the direction yeah you see where
they're going we see where they're going
and the voices that are coming up are
saying this is what we need we need to
set the record straight we need to go
back to morality we need to legislate
against some of these things which both
sides are calling
weird yes so I mean it's like they're
pushing back the water like this right
and the farther they push the water back
the harder it's going to go that's it
that's exactly where we're heading so we
have our cover picture here where you
have the idea of ideologies clashing mhm
and the religious World saying No this
is going too far we have to we have to
move in the other direction and maybe
some cataclysmic events that really
Galvanize people MH can be the stimulus
to do this and we've seen so many we've
seen what happened at the Olympics and
the outcry and the galvanizing of the
Christian world and the opposition to
what's happening in other religious
systems no we are Christian nations
whether this is in Europe whether it's
in England whether it's in the United
States everywhere we're seeing this
movement and so I believe we're at the
pivotal point when these things can
actually start taking place it's like
they're raising the flags right they're
they're getting ready for the the the
March right you know what's interesting
about these two flags being Blended
together that I was just thinking about
both of them are symbols of Freedom yes
but very opposite ends of the spectrum
of freedom I mean I'm assuming that you
know Christianity is is sort of we
should a Christian Nation founding
fathers and principles you know all
these things over here and then it's
like no we want to do whatever we want
to do you know and and that's what's
clashing together I like this image and
also you know the flag on the right here
stands for a republican form of
government nothing to do with the
Republican Party MH uh whereas the one
on the left stands more for a democratic
system where the majority rules are we
there to defend a con stitution or are
we there to bring about majority rule
right if everybody redefin something we
move the goal post just move the gopost
so there are a lot of ramifications in
this study MH but one of the galvanizing
factors I believe was the assassination
attempt on Donald Trump M and so many
voices from the left said that it might
have been
fake and uh there was a huge outcry and
a backlash so as far as our position is
it's irrelevant whether it was real or
whether it was fake yeah what did it
produce but what is the outcome going to
be and we not here to question the
reality thereof or the unreality thereof
we're only interested in
outcomes and so I think we should launch
into it and see to where this is heading
mhm mhm good point so an
interesting thing happened in March of
this year there was this
Evangelical um prophets if you can put
it like that that had a discussion and
this one individual actually predicted
very
closely that there will be an ass
assassination attempt on Trump's life
this is three months before the event m
so let's listen to this I saw Trump
rising up and then I saw an attempt on
his life uh that this bullet flew by his
ear and it came so close to his head
that it busted his drum eardrum and I
saw um he was he fell to his knees
during this time frame and he started
worshiping the Lord he got radically
born again during this time frame I'm
talking people say he's saved now but he
becomes really on fire for Jesus for
what I saw coming wait wait this is
three months prior that that what that
video right there yes yes some Minor
Details are a little bit not quite right
I don't think it busted his eardrum no
but you see it but this is how the devil
works like he mentioned we know he's a
Christian now and all of but this will
change his life completely if you want
to be involved in true Christianity it
has to be word based mhm that was the
premise of the Reformation mhm Thy word
that is the basis for all decision when
it comes to emotions and feelings that
is something that's a paradigm in
Christianity today which is foreign to
what the Bible actually says so just a
warning out there to everyone we have to
be very very careful that we stay
word-based and not emotion based anybody
can say anything right and that's what
Matthew 7 is all about you go to that
chapter and the people at the end
they're saying you know Lord Lord didn't
we do all these things in your name they
appear to be Christian but he says you
know your profession didn't
match your Works in vain they worship me
teaching for Doctrine the Commandments
of men these are very important points
but the point is here is a prediction
mhm and you know
before the administration that is
currently ruling in the United States
came into Power the these very same
prophets were very vocal that there
would be a second term for Trump mhm now
it didn't
materialize but they're of course hoping
that it will materialize this time
around and if it does materialize
according to them then they haven't
given false prophets or false prophecies
MH so whether it happens or not it
doesn't really matter because prophecy
will fulfilled irrespective of who
ruling MH yeah in the time of Elijah it
was God's word that stood not the all
the prophets of Baal and their word that
was confusing the people and if this
really is some kind of like setup thing
or whatever and somehow this guy knows
this piece of information right what a
great way to to rewrite the script to to
clear the Slate If people could fault
Donald Trump saying he's a filthy man
look what he's done oh wow he came
within an inch of his life now he's on
his knees praying he's a good guy from
here forward so res yeah so all of a
sudden you're going to immediately think
like who cares what happened in the past
exactly so whether it is true or whether
it is fake it matter moving forward it's
what happens what's the outcome and also
this stirred up obviously a lot of
emotion even in the comments of this
video there's people that said I was an
atheist and now after this how can I but
believe mhm see so this is really
pushing people into a a sympathetic mhm
um scenario to maybe listen more to
these type of things like you mentioned
in the beginning MH Satan is at work
obviously uh demons and they also have
an influence Soh they this person could
have had a vision you don't know but
it's if it's not come from yes who did
it come from yeah let's have a look at
the next one and see where where this is
heading okay so this is where this is
Trump's first speech after the Assassin
I think so many people have asked me
what happened tell us what happened
please and therefore I will tell you
exactly what happened and you'll never
hear it from me a second time because
it's actually too painful to tell I'm
not supposed to be here tonight not
supposed to be here
[Applause]
you thank
you but I'm not and I'll tell
you I stand before you in this Arena
only by the Grace of almighty
God in watching the reports over the
last few days many people say it was a
providential moment I'm sure that you've
heard a lot of people say this but you
will never be able to convince me that
that last second turn of a head was
anything other than a miracle I
absolutely believe that
I watched I watched the video of what
happened in Butler Pennsylvania about
1550 times I think I was one of about 8
billion people around the world who
watched it and the more I watched it the
more it struck me that everything was
different after that moment everything
this convention is different the nation
is different the world is different
Donald Trump is different when he stood
up after being shot in the face bloodied
and and put his hand up I thought at
that moment that was a transformation
this was no longer a
man well I think that I think it was
divine intervention but the effect that
it had on Donald Trump he was no longer
just a political party's nominee or a
former president or a future president
this was the leader of a nation and in
that moment Donald Trump months before
the presidential election became the
leader of this
nation that was the most obvious to me
and I have to say you know I I I think
it changed him I think a lot of people
are wondering what is this this doesn't
look like politics something bigger is
going on here I think even people who
don't believe in God are beginning to
think well maybe there's something to
this actually so something very
interesting to me about just words i'
I've really studied words right how is
God giving us the government of God he's
using words here's a book collection and
when you read those words enough times
you get this context of who he is right
Devil's copying that he's going I got
some words for you he's handing you
Hollywood right what he did there
psychologically is he just Blended two
words together he's no longer a man
pause divine intervention he just linked
those two concepts together right there
psychologically in your mind cuz you're
trying to follow along and and and those
seeds are going in there that was
amazing so what effect did it have on
the Christian
mindset and even those on the edge of
Christianity it galvanized them God is
in control so whether this leads to a
victory or whether it leads to an
apparent failure it still will have
galvanized those and as the people in
the world are saying and some of those
in the think tanks are saying either way
a victory for Trump or a victory for
Kamala could lead to a civil war oh yeah
cuz if you think this is some Divine
thing and now it's not divinely playing
out because the people are forcing it
yeah you're going to go to war for that
it becomes a religious battle it becomes
a religious Battlefield it's no longer
just a political Battlefield wow it's
it's a religious ideology wow and if one
side or the other gains the ascendancy
or the idea against ascendancy then
religious
legislation can and will be part of the
package deal absolutely for sure for
sure because the other thing is that
you've got the push then of the Olympics
that whole ceremony that's was we'll get
to that in a while but that's a theatrix
part of it that's it if you put it into
perspect prophetic language that was the
King of the South mentality pushing
against this King of the North mentality
mhm mhm I totally believe that so this
is the United States issue now what if
you could expand that to a worldwide
Christian uh realm philosophy well I've
put in just an interesting Slide the
Assassin or uh attempted assassin Thomas
krooks this is him here yes this is him
here and people went digging to see
where he could pop up and this is a real
interesting one maybe I won't say much
we can say afterward what something
Thomas Crooks the shooter had appeared
briefly in it filmed in 2022 at bethl
Park High School where he was a senior
at the time but what was the reason for
the commercial the commercial was part
of black Rock's campaign to Showcase its
commitment to education and community
and featured various students from bethl
Park High School among them was Thomas
Kooks who appeared for a fleeting moment
the footage which had been larg
unnoticed until now suddenly gained
immense attention following the
revelation of Crook's involvement in the
assassination attempt as news of Crook's
appearance in the commercial spread
social media has erupted with reactions
many users continue to express shock and
disbelief While others have begun
speculating about potential connections
between Crooks and black rock the
commercial which had been intended to
promote positive Community engagement
was now viewed through a completely
different lens well we won't make a take
a stand on it it's just something
interesting it's just that people will
be inclined to put this into the
conspiracy theory tank and say that you
know maybe there was something going on
behind the scenes whether or not is
irrelevant yep yep the outcome the
outcome what if even if it was
supernaturally
planned it's still a battle between God
and the forces arrayed against him so it
becomes a religious
war or a religious conflict in the minds
of men MH and this is where where we're
heading mhm and only when that conflict
bubbles over so that the one tries to
get ascendency over the other then you
have to have legislation in order to do
that I mean that's what happened with
the Crusades minus the legislation but
you know religious War one idea could
Prevail the other one could not that's
true you know what's interesting about
that
that kid is is like
um we we've seen videos over the years
of um people being able to take and um
groom basically hypnotize using neural
linguistic programming there's a guy
named Darren Brown he wanted to prove
that you could actually take a um an
assassin and cause him to do an
assassination outside of his even
knowing about it and they set this whole
stage filmed it up there and everything
like this and then they videoed him he
had this this polka AED pattern that
they had a woman in a polka dot dress
she sat down in front of him they set up
a a fake um um scenario with a huge
audience and when the woman with the
Polkka doed thing came out he pulled out
a gun and he shot the guy on stage he's
a famous actor that's on stage and then
they you know everybody's freaking out
because nobody knows about it and and
then they brought the guy back out he
came sat down put the gun back down and
just sort of like went into a sleep mode
and then they said do you know what you
just did and he said no not at all and
they said you don't know anything what
you just did nope not at all and they
brought him into the room and they
showed him the video and the guy just
went white as a ghost like he he was so
shocked I did that they had worked with
him for a year so they had you know
manipulated him over over the course of
a year oh my God Senator Kennedy has
been shot in the head in June 1968
24-year-old Palestinian refugee Sahan
Sahan shot dead presidential candidate
Robert Kennedy in a hotel
Pantry more than 40 years later he still
claims to have no memory of committing
the act I don't remember I must have
been too hypnotized too much out of my
senses to really be aware of of what
happened it was obvious that he had been
uh programmed to kill Robert Kennedy and
programmed to forget that he'd been
programmed allow to enter the French
language which is let's be honest it's
but it's pissing into the wind you can't
you can't
do you remember that woman in the polka
dot dress no remember her turning around
talking to you
no remember that bit no yes at the
moment you will have no memory of this
at all but you're just assassinated a
National Treasure yeah you shot me
but that just shows that there's there's
a wide variety of reasons why you could
cause somebody to go and do that and you
know it's like it was such a strange
thing but I think people need to have
yeah the overarching backing up rather
than getting caught on the details
backing up and going okay where's this
going and what did this cause exactly we
always say you have to be observers yep
don't get sucked into one of the sides
yep step back and look at what's the
outcome yep especially Christianity this
is why it's important where we're
meeting a time that we need to
understand prophecy you know it's really
great to see where is this thing headed
to in Revelation and how did that tie
back to what the elements of Daniel were
dealing with and you know we're seeing
the outcome of that play out today and
if you if you consider that there is a
battle behind the scenes a conflict
between Christ and Satan then there must
be two sides pulling strings the one is
allowed to coer and the other one never
coerces the one is allowed to do things
in secret the other one is never do to
do anything in secret so these are are
powers that are playing behind the
scenes and hypnosis is always part of
the plan I mean if you take uh the Third
Reich mhm those speeches they had
hypnotic effects on the populace and
many were sloon along MH and that that
is a form of coercion so it could be
totally subconscious for even the role
players but the one pulling the strings
the Demonic forces behind the scenes can
manipulate and use those that Third
Reich I'm sure was an emotional charged
situation yeah they know how to
manipulate the masses I me you go back
read you know watch what Edward bernes
came up with with you know applying
sigment freuds things to the masses and
like we know that this technology exists
so so you know we're at the end yes mhm
and you know under hypnosis people can
do things that they will they cannot
possibly remember what happened mhm and
there is a form of total
control and it's interesting that the
spirit of Prophecy warns against
hypnosis but the medical world often
Embraces it MH very true you see and
this next slide actually fits in very
nicely to all of that because I don't
know if many many people know in the
some years back how influential Donald
Trump was in the wrestling scene yeah
that
WWE so you mentioned that before we
started I was shocked by that I was like
what he was a
wrestler well he wasn't a wrestler but
he was in very influential in the you'll
see now in the video as well but what I
just realized is I don't maybe in the US
many people know but I don't think many
people outside of the US even knows this
yeah but look at look WWE maybe will
come to a shock to people that's
Entertainment that's also like Hollywood
style that's actually cheesy
entertainment it's not real yeah cheesy
entertainment and what is you know and
and you have to be a good actor yeah you
have to be a very good actor and how
much influence on the crowd do they put
out it's all about hyping up the crowd
that's really what it's about so doesn't
that make him then excellent at hyping
up crowds really good point in when he
goes to a rally look at the similarity
when you see this video let me just tell
you a couple of things Vince number one
this is peanuts I paid a big price for
raw you know that a big price did I big
I can do whatever the hell I
want about the only thing I can say to
you here tonight is
Donald Trump
yeah oh
oh let me put it very simply
Vince I'm taller than
you I'm better looking than
you I think I think I'm stronger than
you wow
and I'm here to challenge you to a match
in WrestleMania Stone Cold Steve Austin
what's going on over here Donald Trump
is in a world he is not familiar with
this is not real
estate this is the WWE Donald Trump may
have to get his hands dirty
himself may have to grow set and get
invol here hey look at this Donald Trump
Donald Trump Donald Trump Tak oh my God
the Hostile takeover of Donald Trump on
this mcmah has happened at Wrestlemania
23 I didn't think he
was a restraining MC man who's begging
for a reprieve ising oh
no they're both the same actors I mean
they like look the same Vince McMahon
and and you see so that it's just
amazing to me the way that he let's say
gets the crowds riled up at his rallies
yeah isn't much different than no it's
not that's very interesting that's a
very interesting piece of evidence what
does an assassination attempt do to the
minds of people that are sitting on the
fence or people that are already decided
doesn't it cement them in a particular
mindset I think you look rather cruel if
you're then talking smack about somebody
that just almost lost her life correct
MH so what happened to Ronald Dragon
when he survived assassination attempt
let's just go back in history while he
survived in assassination attempt and
his response changed the trajectory of
his
presidency so what transpired over the
next few hours became the stuff of
presidential and political Legend
Reagan's courage over those tense hours
further cemented his relationship and
political standing with the American
public and the same thing is happening
here with Donald Trump it he cementing
his standing and his courage is
something that even his enemies have
mentioned and has turned some of them
around from being anti-trump to Pro prot
Trump so whether this is planned or
whether this is circumstantial and just
happens is irrelevant the fact of the
matter is it's happening MH so an
assassination attempt in Brazil brought
politics into
churches so now you're mixing was that
this year no this article is from this
year this happened in 2007 18 before the
election yeah all right there the
presidential candidate bolsonaro was
stabbed a month before the
2018 election and what did that bring
about though bonaro didn't exit the
attack on his life with the fist pump
and look of defiance his recovery from
the assassination attempt nevertheless
energized his base and grew his
supporters including among significant
members of the Evangelical Christians
who would Propel him to the presidency a
couple of months later so does it have
an effect on the mindset and does
Christianity or the does the church
often get involved and say that it's
divine intervention and therefore choose
a particular path isn't it interesting
that you see sometimes often things
prior to um what happens in the United
States maybe almost like testing the
waters how does this outcome happen or
are we learning from how this happened
and then going hey that's a good idea I
mean the last president that was there
was an assassination attempt on was
Reagan mhm and if you can parallel some
of the events there he was shot and then
there's a lot of parallels that Happ
actor
Republican nobody remembers
him um except fondly you know people
think back rean is a good guy he was a
good president you know people just
they're making a movie about him now
it's going to be released soon I think
it's Dennis Quaid or somebody playing
him so kind of interesting how nobody
people think of Kennedy nobody remembers
him like Oh Kennedy was a bad guy know
it's like oh president Ken he's a good
guy you know he got shot Lincoln oh yeah
he was a good president good guy and
they all sure probably had their own
personal problems right all their
defects of character and what's
interesting is when something like that
takes place in the United States of
America that sentiment spills over to
the rest of the world it does in the
time of Reagan you had thatcherism in
the United king om and you had a
conservative wave moving we have we have
a similar thing happening now the world
is not in the conservative wave it's in
the liberal wave but there are all of
these sentiments that are pushing it
into that conservative wave worldwide
you're also seeing in the entertainment
Spectrum um different actors that you
would have thought never are identifying
as Christian like you know what was the
guy that would that was always do with
the um Alice Cooper and people like that
that you're just like you you were
working for Satan and Russell BR for
brand Brad Pit you name them they're all
just oh yeah I'm Christian
too interesting like they're putting the
vision out there for people like oh yeah
follow this but there there's no
specific Doctrine attached to it it's
just a statement mhm and it's it jumps
the denominational divide many of them
are turning to Catholicism others to
evangelicalism and uh Donald Trump
himself is married to a very devout
Roman Catholic lady so you have this mix
of religions constantly in the Forefront
it's an
ecumenical religion we're all one a
Christianity has to stand together and
then there's the outside enemy the one
that wants to
convert the world to Islam and that's
what's happening in the United Kingdom
now for example where you're saying all
right enough is enough and you have the
discussions we'll talk about them later
that are arising as a result uh who are
you protecting you you liberals out
there are you only protecting one side
or are you protecting the other side
it's getting to be a very interesting
debate for sure no so definitely
assassination attempts really help bring
out a yes um this was just also a quick
article on the slov Slovakian prime
minister who opposed the World Health
Organization pandemic treaty shot in an
assassination attempt that was a while
ago so this assassination attempt which
occurred as he was leaving a government
meeting comes only a few days after
Slovakia announced that it would not
support the who pending pandemic
agreement that's another interesting one
you know where you have this world
govern government push in a particular
direction but these people come out
Heroes at the end of the process and
they galvanized the political world into
a particular
mindset and you know the health issue
was also a very important point in the
election and who was right and who was
wrong and who pushed it to the point of
coer Etc that's all part of the debate
at the moment One World Government
against your
nationalistic
orientation that's another divide that's
taking place in the world and that also
brings religion always in it because you
always have the the um One World type of
view will be the more secularised View
and the other one is the Christian um
view the like this if you want to get
rid of the globalist and all of that
it's always the Christian side
freedom and autonomy against what a
greater body wants in this particular
case they mention sorus as the one who
is the billionaire globalist who is
funding the left ideology and then you
have Elon Musk who is also a billionaire
and he's talking on the other side of
the divide and you know people are so
riled up that they actually begin to
hate
certain people like sorus for example
and the question is then why are they
allowed to operate with so much Freedom
why are they allowed to give their funds
to projects like flooding the borders
for
example why why is this all
permitted it should be able to be
controlled quite simply right but it's
never controlled and it's always those
people out there that are causing the
problem it's like front
organizations who are the real Puppet
Masters behind the scenes real hard to
follow the the blame I appreciate how
you mentioned that that division that
that is polarizing people and that was
the thing that worried me most about
what was happening during the pandemic
it wasn't whether you get a vaccine or
not to me it was like I was so concerned
about how are God's people treating each
other during that time are we extending
Grace and Mur is our character going to
be worse by the time this is over or is
it going to be better exactly and that
was a big issue you saw the way people
kind of divided during that whole
situation and I mean it was like we're
going to fight over this like you know
in in a way that it Ian it really Drew
lines in some Churches and things but I
think it will also the same will happen
with this election a lot of people if
you don't if you're not an observer and
you're going to be sucked into one of
the two sides MH you're going to make a
it's going to get messy and people
like they won't like you if you don't
make a choice for one other you're in
the crosshairs exactly so this is just
some videos on what happened after the
assassination temp and what were some of
the comments that was made fight fight
fight fight
fight we got Time come on hey we are in
the fight for the soul of our nation we
are in a fight for our kids and our
grandkids a fight that we can never
imagine I believe wholeheartedly Donald
Trump and Butler County's JD Vance are
the last chance to save our country
politically I'm afraid if we lose this
one it's going to take a civil war to
save the country and it will be saved
it's the greatest experiment in the
history of mankind and if we come down
to a civil war I'm glad we got people
like schmidi and the bikers for Trump on
our side if you don't vote we're not
going to win the election if you do vote
we're going to win in a landslide too
big to rig we're going to win in a
landslide but Christians you know you'll
go to church every
Sunday and Pastor Paula White and all of
the people I understand they're doing
lock boxes in churches where people
don't even have to go to vote they can
now vote in church and if you do that
we're going to win by numbers that
nobody's ever seen before you know you
have tremendous power but you just don't
know that but you have to use that power
Christians are a group that's known not
to vote very much you have to go out at
least this election just give us in get
us into that beautiful white house vote
for your congressmen and women vote for
your Senators we will change this
country for the better this country will
be great again like never before so Mark
Zuckerberg called me first of all he
called me a few times he called me after
the event and he said that was really
amazing it was very brave and you know
and he actually announced he's not going
to support a Democrat because he can't
because he respected me for what I did
that day I think what I did maybe was a
norm to me it was a normal response but
I was called by Mark Zuckerberg
yesterday the day before on this same
subject and he actually apologized he
said they made a mistake etc etc and
they're correcting the mistake uh Google
nobody call from Google nice pause I
mean what he's doing there I mean just
putting the ballot boxes in the churches
is too close to blending church and
state right off the bat yes I mean there
is so many things going on here that
that you are seeing the writing on the
wall yeah now a few years ago if you
said that there would be Christian
legislation passed in this country you
were regarded as on the border of
insanity right can never happened in
this country tin hat conspiracy theorist
conspiracy and it's the greatest
conspiracy story in the Bible but it's
happening mhm whether contrived or not
is irrelevant the fact of the matter is
Bible prophecy will be fulfilled because
God cannot be wrong that's right because
history has proved that prophecy gets
fulfilled whether we like it or not you
can go and build a statue of solid gold
from head to toe to say Babylon will
never
fall but it will fall that's right
that's right exactly that's right
interesting and and you know every time
that that that you have examples in the
Bible of this um sort of world dominance
right yes there's worship attached to
that always you need to worship and
every time that worship is forced God
has to step in there's a lot of people
on the internet that that I think that
this particular message and and and scen
that where it's going to play out in
this worship Arena there's a lot of
people that are linking the mark of the
beast to some sort of you know chip
you're gonna take and this and that and
it's all just kind of taking your focus
off of what's going on something that's
happening over there in the Middle East
it's kind of like not focusing
necessarily on you know this this is
these ideologies that are Waring against
each other like Daniel 11 I truly do
believe King of the North King of the
South two mindsets that are fighting
against each other and and um you know
the religious
world will dominate because that's what
the Bible says and then it will force
that worship and if you want to
Galvanize a people then the rhetoric has
to get more and more aggressive MH so if
you want to push people into their camp
and keep them there then just increase
the negative rhetoric on the other side
mhm and we'll see that in the next one
yeah this video will surely show that
I'd like to punch him in the face I said
if we were in high school I'd take him
behind the gym and beat the hell out of
him punch some people people in the face
when was the last time an actor
assassinated a president they're still
going to have to go out and put a bullet
in Donald Trump and that's a
fact look as his character is stabbed to
death where is John wilk's Booth when
you need him this
way that's it right there pull it up I
have thought an awful lot about blowing
up the White House I will go and take
Trump out tonight I'm usually really
fast to
talk wow I don't know if I have
words it's you know I think I mentioned
this yesterday when we were talking is
uh you know these are the the Democrats
right the the people on the left of the
spectrum the ones that don't that want
more gun reform more gun control they
don't want they don't want guns but
there's a whole lot of violent language
in those comments I mean we could have
been watching a WWF episode right here
now what will this do just
psychologically what will it do to the
mindset of those that support the
agenda of the right yeah won't it
Galvanize it absolutely won't it make
them close ranks yeah it's not going to
show their Christianity they're going to
take the approach of fighting fire with
fire instead of turning the other cheek
yes exactly you see so it's so
much riling up mhm that either way the
election goes it can be a problem you've
we've listened to the how many people
now talking about a civil war mhm yeah
that was interesting that he kind of
made that threat that came out I mean
that almost felt like it was a threat
what's it going to take not the first
one it's going to take it won't and
they've ained I mean even from those
from the Heritage
Foundation that it could be a bloodless
Revolution if Trump wins but if the
other side wins it could be a bloody
Revolution
I come full circle in this response and
just want to encourage you with some
substance that we are in the process of
the second American Revolution which
will remain bloodless if the left allows
it to be I mean we live in Tennessee
here and I need to move further away
both sides are saying that so we're
living in a very interesting time now
the Olympic uh events in France are
playing right into this now France is
such a fascinating country you know you
had the French Revolution and I believe
that Revelation 11 talks about that
tremendous mind shift in ideology where
you had the the middle- ages mindset of
the church rules absolutely to the
mindset of the church has no say
whatsoever do what thou Wilt is the
whole of the law uh Liberty Liberty to
do what thou
wilth and that has basically been the
mindset since the French
Revolution I I think it's a very clever
deploy if you're thinking about demonic
Puppet Masters behind the scene because
the Bible says it's a philosophy that
comes from the bottomless pit and this
philosophy has taken over the world
before we had
monarchies after you had
democracies now even Aristotle already
said the final step before tyrrany is
democracy because eventually it will
become so bad and uh the rule of law
will just disappear because everybody
wants to be without the rule of law that
eventually it becomes so chaotic that
the only solution is tyranny you desire
somebody to make some sort of rural
decision you need a strong man mhm now
who's that strong man going to be what
is that picture that they showed of
Donald Trump with his fist in the air
what does that show a weak man or a
strong man a strong man yeah they said
there was a transformation in this man I
mean there's they're using all the
language of like you know he's like
reborn I mean you know just in a movie
making there's there's you know um that
guy Joseph Campbell that wrote a a hero
without or a hero Thousand Faces hero of
hero's journey a man a man with a
thousand faces and it follows thisy
basically you can fit every single story
into this cycle and it's pretty wild
I've seen people do this with cartoons
with Star Wars with you name it it
follows the cycle the only one that fits
outside of that cycle that they don't
know what to do with is Jesus he does
not fit that model and so you know this
kind of thing right here is following in
that cycle it's interesting all right if
you if you look at this whole campaign
and the rhetoric that is associated with
the campaign and these people are
proclaimed Christians I mean whether
it's the Biden Camp they are stor
Christian Catholics for example Biden or
even Pelosi that was speaker for a long
time and the other side is also claiming
to be strong Christian do you see true
Christian sentiments coming out or do
you see something else true Christianity
really is a you know humbleness
meekness you know all the fruits of the
spirit right seeking after righteousness
I mean think of all those character
traits that that guy that came out even
Trump fight fight fight that's not the
true sentiment Jesus is going to the
Cross Peter steps up no we're going to
take these guys out we're going to fight
right takes the guy's ear off Jesus
walks around I mean I would I can't wait
to see that scene Jesus picking up the
ear and put walking back over on the man
and putting it back on being like guys
this is not how I want it it's amazing
that they still took him after that that
was the religious mindset of the day
that he grew up with as a Jew you know
it was like we need to get rid of the
Romans they're in our faces we got to
rebel against these guys they had
zealots that were killing them and
they'd get in trouble and be crucified
over it I mean their mindset was
anti-roman and will go to violence to
accomplish that in Jesus's day they had
this same thing and it's interesting
that an played such a prominent role
yeah can an A change the course of
history it's certainly yeah yeah not the
tongue he didn't cut out his tongue all
right so here it was an event that took
place in the United States of America
and now we moved to
France and you had this this
uh activity that was going on there that
was supposedly mocking the Last Supper
although they say it wasn't it was the
Olympic guards they were mocking but
nevertheless did that event Galvanize
Christianity in the entire world what
happened in France just after that they
came together in their
thousands on the side of Christianity
and Jesus they had rallies as a
consequence it is a galvanizing time
when when Christians are saying we're
being bullied we we've been bullied by
Islam we're being bullied Now by
secularism enough is enough what do you
do when you get power under those
conditions you legislate that's right
you're going to make it happen so that
people don't put you back in that
situation yeah all right let's move a
little bit further and let's become
defiant against this separation of
church and state so the Louisiana
governor he ordered that the Ten
Commandments be displayed in the
schools and that the kids that were
opposed to it or the parents of the kids
should tell their kids just don't look
at it but we're not taking it away it's
staying there then the the left said we
will take you to court and he says I
welcome it I want it to go all the way
to the Supreme
Court now if we look at the con at the
composition of the Supreme
Court are they going to be on the side
of the separation of church and state or
will they redefine that
boundary if you look at the
majority on the Supreme Court that will
give you an indication yes exactly what
is the majority it's a Roman Catholic
majority and who put that majority in
place wasn't it Donald Trump MH I've
also heard that a lot of the generals of
our armies um the generals are all
Catholic a large portion of them yes so
I mean you think if you got the dominoes
or the chest pieces in the right
positions uh we're we're set up here
interesting about your photo here um
that says Declaration of Independence
and it looks like the Ten Commandments I
mean who nobody makes a document with
two circles on the top and there's
another one on the other side that says
United States Constitution and it's also
like something written in stone I mean
there's there's a lot of of
ofur not only there but also the French
Revolution ution they brought out the
Declaration of Human Rights and that was
also in the form of the Ten Commandments
interesting but above it they had the
Fran hat which was the Hat of the sun
god Mitra that's the yeah the and then
you had the allseeing eye which is the
main emblem of the Jesuits and there's
no doubt that the French Revolution was
led by the Jesuits we all know that Vol
was a Jesuit and many of the role
players were Jesuit was connected
somehow and this all happened in the
time period when the papacy received a
mortal wound it had lost its power it
had no more power to legislate what if
you push it to the opposite extreme and
you say all right let's deregulate
everything and let's lead the world to
the chaos that we have now then we'll
swing the pangel back they'll beg for
the they'll beg for the control of the
church over the state isn't that where
we're heading mhm so is it a form of
hegelian dialectic creating opposites so
that you can create a synthesis in the
end absolutely now Jamie Rasin is the
guy who was in charge of the uh
impeachment of Donald Trump well last
night I was most worried um about the
Supreme Court's prospective imminent
abdication of its very clear duty to
disqualify Donald Trump from the ballot
under Section 3 of the 14th Amendment
and what that might mean if their
decision says that it's really up to
Congress on January 5th or January 6
2025 um to disqualify him at the
counting of the Electoral College votes
which really could lead to something
akin to Civil War if that's if that's
what the suggestion is which is what I
think I heard so what he's saying here
is if he is elected
we're going to charge him with
Insurrection under the 14th Amendment
Section 3 and disqualify him before he
is officially sworn in as president of
the United States so they will overturn
the the
vote he is so serious about this now
remember this is the way these people
have been working they have they just
say it and because they have the media
it just becomes that then they just
replaced now remember Harris was um she
was incompetent she was a joke everybody
in the media knew that everybody said
that in fact the stories were just a
week before she can't keep her staff she
is so hated she's a monster in the
office and a week later after hearing
that for 3 years a week later the new
new reality is that it's kamot like
Camelot that she's going to bring back
the JFK years because she's so beloved
and so smart and so
unifying so when they say things they
just expect everyone to believe it and
the sad thing is about 30% of the
population believes it what do you think
of K
Harris uh I think she is a politician
yeah and uh she's interested in the
accumulation of power and control do you
think she believes in
anything uh I think she believes in
government like most marxists yes I
think she is a Marxist do you think that
she can
win absolutely she can win this is this
is going to be a great
test of the power of the
media to take
someone who formerly was universally
disliked and transformed them into a
Godlike figure and they will use
everything that they have to try to do
that the question is are the American
people smart enough to see through it
well the bottom line of that one
is even if the left
wins what is the seed that has just been
planted if you want to save the nation
if if you want to save the world and
they're saying if you want to save it
from World War II mhm then the only
solution is to take the power back and
that's why they're talking about
Revolution that's why they're talking
about Civil War so either way whether
the left wins in this election or
whether the right wins it's going to be
a very fascinating time could it lead to
a time of
trouble such as we have never seen
before yeah could it lead to a little
time of trouble and
eventually then because of religious
legislation MH lead to a great time of
trouble MH is the table late can it
happen you bet all it takes is a spark
right
YH it really makes you wonder you know I
I look over the history of the world and
there's some been some bad times that
our world has endured and if Jesus's
words are right there's going to be a
time that no other people have ever
experienced this I think it's going to
get pretty bad all right but there's
another there's another side to the
story let's look at this slide over here
Trump greets Netanyahu at Mar Lago and
says World War I could happen if Harris
wins so this is no longer speculation
that the people are talking about these
issues this is a reality we'll see how
it goes but if all works out if we win
it will be very simple it's all going to
work out and very quickly Trump said if
we don't you're going to end up with
major wars in the Middle East and maybe
a third world war what
if he becomes a
peacemaker and suddenly Russia lays down
its arms Ukraine gets silent the Middle
East is calmed down and the world shouts
peace peace at last what does the Bible
say happens then then sudden destruction
comes upon a woman as travail Upon A
where is travail upon a woman so all
sides could actually fulfill biblical
prophecy right yep both sides and and
interesting also like you've mentioned
before that the media is playing a big
role MH both sides is acknowledging it
exactly and both sides are have the
rhetoric right so it's very interesting
to watch Dr Carson on there talking
about how the media is playing such a
role in Kamala and no doubt it is but
it's also playing a role for Trump you
know it's both sides are putting out
their own rhetoric and accusing the
other one of doing the thing that
they're doing so they if you look at
this there's no peace talks now it's
only civil war and War and War yeah
that's that's a fascinating element that
but like yeah but like you mentioned
what if there's a peac maker in all of
this sh yes interesting but even like
the idea that they're going to make um
you know Kamal like a Godlike figure you
know that was kind of fascinating too
because I don't know it's like they
don't they don't they don't care about
God right but didn't you also mention
earlier that there was a lot of this
nuances in the speech that made him a
Godlike figures only almost got two Gods
against each other yeah interesting so
now let's put the Islamic issue into
into the fry and say all right now we
have all of these internal issues with
the the left's policies which are riling
up Christians let's add the Islamic
issue in there and we have the riots in
in Britain and what happened in Germany
Germany has shut down one of the
country's largest and oldest mosques and
ordered a ban on the Nationwide Shia
Muslim organization that runs it for
religious
extremism dozens of police raided hambur
Blue Mosque on Wednesday morning as well
as 53 other properties across Germany in
one of the most significant crackdowns
on political islamism in the country in
years the interior Ministry said it was
formerly Banning the Islamic Center of
Hamburg and its Affiliated organizations
for preaching totalitarian rule
aggressive anti-Semitism and support for
the terror group
hisbah three other mosques in Berlin
Frankfurt and Munich have also been
raided and
closed so so we're having a backlash
what the Christian world let's call it
that for lack of a better term is saying
enough we want to go back to values of
Christianity and like we said in our
previous discussion even if you're an
atheist they're saying we want those
cultural norms to rule over us and not
these other Norms to rule over us and
the Battleground for the implement of
the mark of the beast is the Christian
world the rest will follow for economic
reasons or whatever other reasons
secular reason there might be but the
Battleground for the mind is the
Christian
world yeah and and then you've got the
people that are not actually open
Christian like Elon Musk they also got a
lot to say about all of this yes so why
is Elon mus clashing with the UK
government over farri riots so on Sunday
musk tweeted that Civil War is
inevitable in the UK in response to a
post claiming that open borders and
migration had led to the protests in one
response to a post that claimed that an
armed Muslim Patrol group had attacked
civilians and a News Network crew musk
directly tweeted at Prime Minister strus
asking why aren't all community
protected why are you
selectively as the left protecting some
and not others why are you not
pro-christian but you're acting as
though you're
proslim why are you allowing these
things to happen and look what happened
to those little children and all of
these emotional things that are
happening in the world today
irrespective of how they happened and
why they happened they are galvanizing
the Christian world into saying so far
and further that's interesting to hear
about the the the the wars around the
world right in the horses right that are
coming isn't the red horse the war the
black horse the death the pale horses
kind of a mixture of all these right and
and in the order of the horses coming
does it mention the red being the first
one the red the red horse is the one
that has the martydom as its symbol yes
the White Horse the White Horse is the
first one horse is the first one so so
does that kind of tie into um there's
like War then you have pestilence after
the war then you have kind of this
mixture of all three and then the
obviously Jesus right and the death is
the result of the wars and the the death
of the of the truth as a result of the
blending of paganism with with uh with
the
truth what's fascinating here is that
Elon Musk tweeted and he's not uh very
strong professed Christian unless there
is more bravery to stand up for what is
fair and right Christianity will perish
um yeah go ahead cuz I know what you're
going to mention his profile picture his
profile picture I've seen that before
he's wearing that
that yeah he's wearing BFF like satanic
outfit making a comment about
Christianity is weird Catholic is this
interesting or is that not we had a
discussion about secret societies let's
not get all yeah you know Twitter and
busted and involved in all of that but
if you put it all together it's like
we're living in a in an enatic circus
yeah it's a WWF it is I thought it was
Catholic because he seems like he
recently met with a pope with like five
of his kids or something he met with him
but that doesn't make him Catholic no I
I know but I just I thought he was
because he's not very outspoken about
his Christianity so yeah this is again
pushing for standing up for your
Christianity and I believe we should
stand up but not with fists that's right
and this was also pushing towards stuff
like that so what do you how did you
change it I guess I'll cut right to it
if you can fix El Salvador what are the
lessons for the rest of us what did you
do first we're literally the murder
capital of the world yes and we turn it
into the safest country in the Western
Hemisphere we safer than any other
country in the western hemisphere which
is you know it was if I if I would have
said that 5 years ago they would said
that I was crazy right so you did that
in just a couple years yes we did that
in basically in three
years so what just bottom line it for us
what's the
formula well I can tell you the official
formula and the and the real
formula okay so the official formula is
that we did a plan I mean we did a plan
it's not that when I say official I'm
not mean it's a lie it's just you know
the the official one we did a a a a plan
that was comprised of faces yeah we we
we roll up the faces and then and then
we we we went after them okay so that's
the official that's the official yes
that's the official one what what's
what's the real it's a miracle it's a
miracle yeah it's I love that what do
you mean yeah it's a miracle you know uh
and uh I B I basically said well we I
mean it's we we we are we're looking at
into an impossible impossible Mission
here so we
pray and uh and we and
we you prayed in the meeting yes yes of
course several times yeah yeah what did
you pray for now to wisdom to to win the
war to have I thought at the time that
we will have civilian casualties so we
we said we pray that the civilian
casualties will be as low as
possible and we didn't have any CI
civilian
casualties and was everyone in the
meeting comfortable with that yes yes
they every all my security cabinet are
believers they all believe in God we're
we're a a secular country of course but
we all believe in God so you almost you
almost think this is the power of the
media right here running around showing
you what's the solution for all this yes
what is the solution that gets put out
and people you know Christianity this
gets around and people are going to be
like yeah yeah yeah yeah don't they long
for the solution yes let bring
Christianity into it and and that's the
crazy thing that's going to happen right
now is because we want people to come to
the gospel we want the world to respond
to God now can you imagine when it
finally happens and everybody says this
is the way this is the way of Peace this
is what we've been looking for and one
little obstinate group says excuse me
there's an error here we following the
Commandments of men and not the
Commandments of God how popular are you
going to be yeah not you're not going to
be popular not at all M so because of
99% that it looks good because who
doesn't want peace who doesn't want um
your country to flourish and not be the
murder capital of the world mhm but like
you just mentioned that's only 90.9% of
the the story because there's 1% poison
in there and that little group is going
to be standing out like a sore thumb mhm
yeah you mix into that um natural
disasters that are completely like
getting you
know blown out of proportion if if you
would Satan's up in his Laboratories
like causing all these things to happen
right and and then it's like the acts of
God are happening because this little
group over here are not they're not
playing ball correctly yes let's have a
look at the next one okay so don't know
if anybody knows but Steve bennon he
used to be in the government of trump
and then he went to jail recently for
his unwillingness to appear before the I
think the committee very deep questions
so I think we're heading towards a
constitutional crisis this country's
never had before yeah and uh and that's
one of the reasons I think I'm going to
prison they want to send me to prison in
July to make sure that the I think some
of the strongest or more more aggressive
of President Trump's president Trump's
Advocates are are taking off the uh are
off the playing field I think that's
right at some point it you just have to
say no no um last question so you you've
got four months you're facing what do
you plan to do with that time like what
are you going to read what are you going
to spend your time doing in well I I you
know I I have a pretty strict regimen as
is so I'll continue on I I do a lot of
uh spiritual exercises following uh St
Ignatius Loyola you know different uh
spiritual exercises that come out of the
Catholic church although I'm a uh I'm a
uh
I I would actually say if you look at
our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ I would
call myself a pre-christian I I wouldn't
want to insult His Name by saying I'm a
Christian given the the the very tough
and high high standard that this is
where extremism is coming from your
government has turned against you not
our country the government a this
illegitimate regime has taken over the
apparatus of the United States
government and is enforcing dictatorial
power and we have to stand up for it
just like the Revolutionary generation
stood up to the dictatorial power of the
crown uh the and people like the British
East India Company what they hate most
is Christianity for sure well you're a
brave and magnanimous man um and so God
bless you good
luck Tucker thanks look forward to
seeing you other
side thank you Steve I almost want to
say I rest my
case right because from the beginning I
believe that the Puppet Masters that
have been used by greater popup Master
than them even are the Jesuits M I
believe that the Jesuits were behind the
French Revolution and the whole
liberalization of humanity I believe
that the Jesuits are behind the
reunification and moving back to
absolute papal
Authority and that the power should be
given back to the Beast and I think
these government officials have just
confirmed that suspicion call it
conspiracy if you
want yeah when he says he's following
ous Lola who is a Jesuit he was the
founder he was the founder of the Jesuit
and these spiritual exercises are
hypnotic yeah they are the ones that
lead to an experiential religion which
is not based on faith right but based on
exercise yeah I mean he could have said
anything and he chose to say that of all
things it's crazy and you remember I
don't know if you were on some of the
shows that James uh we had on and he was
talking about how a lot of these
dictators throughout history they were
like look we wanted to study how to do
this and we studied the best model there
was the Catholic
church I think if there's any question
yeah the the the evidence is here let
people decide for themselves mhm real or
unreal is not not the point outcome what
is going to be the outcome we're going
to see the implementation of the mark of
the beast we're going to see the power
by the 10 horns given unto the Beast
we're going to see an attack on God's
people as a
consequence removing the final
opposition to the government that the
Devil Himself has set up on this planet
he wants to remove any opposition and
God's answer will be the plagues but
before that there's a loud cry and I
want to be part of it I don't know about
you guys amen amen amen it's it's
amazing too because God is very clear in
the book of Acts it says that he pours
out his Spirit on those who obey him yes
right and I remember studying one day
and and something kind of clicked I was
looking in the Book of Joel chapter 2
and it talks about all the the people
that God's spirit falls on remember it
says your sons and your daughters your
men's servants your maid servants it's
like listing these groups of people and
then you go to the Sabbath commandment
and do you know the list of those people
is almost the same beautiful your sons
and your daughters your manservants your
maid servants and it's God saying I pour
out my spirit on those who obey me those
who worship me in spirit and in truth
and the Sabbath is part of that I mean
anybody who is within thy Gates right
that's why it's important to practice
that now to look into that you know I
hope anybody out there that's watching
if you have not dived into these kind of
topics I pray that you're probably
familiar if you're watching this on
what's up Prof you're familiar with
their Ministry but um maybe perhaps you
haven't looked into the Sabbath issue
maybe you haven't looked into Endtime
prophecy events um tell us where we can
learn more about that if somebody
doesn't know where to start where would
you tell them to start Martin where
would you start well I think a good
place can be you can go to our website
Clash ofm minds.com our YouTube channel
is at Clash of Minds The whatsa Prof
series is on there we recently started a
new series what is truth with Walter's
son and my cousin it's a well there's
some interesting things coming in that
one as well yeah and I think we are
also there's a lot of planning um of
getting tools into people's hands with
an app and some Bible study material and
we've also recently well pretty soon
we'll have a um a Evangelical school
that we'll be running two or three times
a year so go to our website and watch
out for that I love it Keith where can
uh they learn more about Bible
topics uh well if you're interested in
Bible topics we have a school as well
it's a bible school that we've partnered
with another organization on it's uh you
can reach it at
ls. school it's just straight Bible
studies and teaching you can ask
questions on there and and just go
through the Bible and study it and
discover what the truth of the word is
thank you guys so much for joining us
for this awesome discussion um I'm going
to have a lot to chew on and I'm sure
I'm going to be laying my head down
tonight just thinking about some of
these clips that we just watched that
are completely crazy but you know I I I
really am glad that God has told us
what's going to happen before because I
think that we know how this is going to
play out when you study it and you you
understand that's what Thessalonians
talked about we brought that up you know
when they say peace and safety and
sudden destruction comes upon them right
it says but you are not in darkness
right that that day should overtake you
as a thief we are all children of the
light we're Children of the day
therefore let us not sleep but put on
the breastplate and the helmet of
Salvation And um our Salvation is coming
look up look up and I want to make an
appeal to God's people to unite on what
we know is truth let's stop arguing and
fighting about non-essentials we're
right at the borders of Canaan let's
unite on the issues that are important
in this time amen good call good call
thank you guys for coming on thank you
guys for joining us please like this
video share it with somebody that you
know would get a blessing from this if
you haven't subscribed to our ministry
or their Ministry clash of the minds
please go to these YouTube channels and
a simple way that you can help us out is
just give the video a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel it's like one
little click that's a great way to to
help us get higher up in the algorithm
but we're going to ask you for something
even more special than this I believe
that we're coming into a very dangerous
time and place in the world and we need
your prayers please pray that these
Ministries can actually continue forward
to continue to put out messages like
this because we've experienced a few
months back them taking the plug out of
the wall with um with um being able to
take our content down offline I'm sure
you guys have experience that as well so
we are on borrowed time pray for us if
you want to support so we can get these
things out there faster please join up
with us and partner with us so that we
can ready as many people to see Jesus
coming in the clouds we love you guys
thank you for watching we'll see you
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
hey subscribe to little
stud if you want to learn Spanish a
great way will be watching our videos
for
practice do you have questions about the
Bible that you've been struggling to
find the answers for video Bible study
or VBS for short is a YouTube channel
that answers your Bible questions in 5
minutes or less check out these easy to
understand comprehensive videos talking
about everything from what happens when
you die to why does God allow suffering
make it your goal to deepen your
relationship with Christ this year and
subscribe to video bible study on
YouTube to help you along your journey
[Music]